when we can live longer and healthier
lives there's the question of what
happens to many different areas of our
lives the family is one that's super
important what happened the last time we
doubled human life expectancy human life
expectancy in 1850 in the United States
was 43 years today it's around 80 years
we've roughly doubled it already and so
the question is is well what happened
family life during that time and if you
look you can see that the age of first
marriage has gone up significantly the
age of first-time mothers has gone up
already I mean right now we're in the
era of the 40 year old mother and I
think that at some point there'll be a
time when we're in the era of the 70
year old mother we're at the point where
we're going to see new life phases
coming along and so a lot of scholars
are focused on the idea of retirement
right now and how the definition of
retirement is changing right now we
think of it as a period in time at the
end of our lives where we take time off
to relax go traveling and that kind of
thing but I think in a longer lived
world where people can be healthier for
longer periods of time and work longer
retirement might be redefined to mean
something like large chunks of time that
you take out of your life to go get
re-educated or even take off time to
have children or do something else
because if you could live to be 150
years old in a relatively healthy state
then you might want to have more than
one career that that requires a lot of
education and then with longer lives we
might also have other periods of life
that for instance when when we extended
our life expectancy a new phase of life
came along called adolescence and that
didn't used to exist before we used to
go straight from childhood to adulthood
but as we lived longer and healthier
this new phase of life came along called
adolescence and now scholars are
starting to see another phase of life
which they're calling adult lessons and
that's the time after adolescence but
you're not quite an adult yet and as we
live longer and longer we might see new
phases of life like that
you